right the following as mixed noodles
well the first thing that you've got to
number four okay now this is an improper
fraction why is it improper yeah okay so
this number either topping this number
on the bottom right usually a small one
here in the big one here what do they
call bowing rather than coin with one on
top okay yeah this one's the numerator
and the other ones not denying it yeah
okay well let's try it out let's see
what happens right now the first thing I
do before I do any conversion sure
let's find out the first thing you want
do is what we did over here will just
simplify right I can reduce this down
what's the highest common factor
it's two is it so that gives me five
over two okay now think with me
carefully this is tricky okay you need
to work out well how many times this is
the denominator go into the mirror and
the answer is twice you can't go three
times because you need six and we don't
have six so we can go twice right now
here's the way that I would write this
plugin right this is four plus one love
juice see what I've done I got the four
from you said it was twice twice times
two
okay first one now because I've broken
it up like that I can write this as two
separate fractions right 4 over 2 and 1
over 2 now and forever - you can
simplify you can reduce what's the
highest common factor it's 2 this
becomes just - there you go
all right let's try a harder one let's
see ok so what we've got here is 28 over
10 so like I said the very first step is
simplified don't do anything before you
simplify because um you know once you
simplify the numbers are nice and small
much easy to work with so what's my
highest common factor it's - right so
what am I going to get cocky tell me
when I cancel out reduce it what would
you get okay okay now I'm gonna do the
same thing I'm gonna ask how many times
is five you go into 14 and again like
this it goes twice again right so if
it's twice right it should be 10 plus 4
stop and think where do I get the 10
from when I get the 10 from its because
you told me twice so that's 2 5 is it
okay slow down where did the number come
from what I broke it up into 10 and 4
because you told me that 5 goes into 14
twice so I pulled out those two fires
right 10 all right so now break it Punk
there's one of the fractions and there's
the other ones okay and 10 to the 5 is 2
so you're gonna get 2 and 4 this is
tricky let's do it one more time this
time you guys walk me through let's see
let's do okay now you guys don't need to
simplify here do you
because what's the highest common factor
very violent
you can't divide yet it's just 1 so
therefore I can skip next to this next
immediately to this next step so I'm
gonna think how many times does 5 got if
they threaten the answer is 6 times all
right so I'm gonna take those six fives
out that's 30 plus 3 is that okay see
what I've done right so now I've got the
30 over 5 he
the three over five they're 30 divided
by five just like you told me is six
going through okay now can I just give
you a bit of a caution
okay give you a question see what I've
done here in in breaking apart the
numerator okay you can only break apart
the numerator you can't break apart the
denominator let me show you right let's
give an example let's say a quarter okay
just have a look at what would happen I
can say that's one over two plus two so
you're like cool I can break this apart
just like with Briggs life so far so
that's like 1 over 2 plus 1 over 2 right
what's 1/2 plus 1/2 it's one whoa cool I
just had one complain right yeah okay so
what's my point it's it's not money for
free it's not true the core is not one
because you can't break the pot the
denominator right none of these actually
uh true right
so numerators you can you can break them
up denominators not so much okay so
there you go that's how to convert from
what was this an improper fraction to
mix dragging right now do you reckon you
could have a go at doing the other way
somewhat a question five pick a question
g g 5g go straight for the three two and
three fifths okay so these things were
already a mixed fraction right I'll go
the other way
yeah yeah mixed fraction mix numeral
same thing different names all right
yeah okay so this thing's a mixed
numeral mixed fraction right so I want
to turn it into more yes but how do I
get this question how do I change it I'm
gonna do exactly what I do keep but in
Reverse right because it's the opposite
thing so if I were to
right this is two plus three-fifths okay
I want to write this as a fraction with
the denominator 5 so how would I write 2
as a fraction with the denominator of 5
well it's 10 over 5 isn't it - yes I'm
multiplied by 5 top and bottom okay
right so therefore then I add 3 over 5
over here I've got 10 and 3 and that's
just a 13 yeah good question right let
me um maybe I should put an extra line
in here because that is that is the
question to ask in here right
the dilemma I had was I had to and had
3/5 I made to mix them together somehow
right so what I did was I put them I
made the compensate language which is
denominated 5 so here's the way I did it
I multiplied it by 5 over 5
it doesn't change the number that's just
one yeah multiple two times one doesn't
change so therefore two times five is
ten
yeah so that's where I got 10 over 5
from okay and the reason I did that is
so that these two guys would talk to
each other and mix together and become
an improper fraction okay should we do
one more converting and then I'm gonna
let you guys do your virtual team pick
one we'll just eg I need more space
so yep the arrow in 5g is point towards
yeah yeah that's right actually really
this line is just the whole line is in
between what did you tell me eat is that
what you asked you know five and five
six okay okay can you see it tricky five
and five six all right now what did I do
here have a look at how I did it right
I've got the five right here I've got
the five and I've got the five CST's
okay so what a turn this guy into a
fraction or the Sikhs right so maybe
I'll stick in an extra line I'll say
that's five times 6 over 6 okay why did
I do that the reason why is because it's
going to give me a denominator 6 which
is what I want okay so you see I went
from 5 times 6 is 30
and so you end up with 35 over 6 that
way you weigh yeah now that's not the
way the only way to set it out what I'm
encouraging me to go this way because it
makes it really clear where the numbers
come from the logic is clear okay so if
you're what way works and you're
consistently getting the right answers
that's fine okay but if it's not this is
a way that you can set out that'll help